welcome to the show.
Let's get right into it.
I've been waiting since the third democratic
debate last Thursday to get some post debate
polling yesterday early.
We got one post debate poll but a one is just
one alas and I wanted to wait until we had
at least a second post debate poll and we
now have that so we're going to be able to
look at them in detail.
Um, let's sort of refresh the backstory.
The backstory of course being that basically
since even before he formally announced his
candidacy, I think it was in April, former
vice president Joe Biden has been leading
the polls.
We've seen Bernie Sanders in second place
for quite some time, but one of the storylines
of polling for the last several months has
been that as Joe Biden sort of drops off from
what was a round a 44 ish percent high at
one point months ago.
It Has Been Elizabeth Warren who has been
sort of steadily picking up one to one and
a half points every single month with Bernie
Sanders basically remaining in this second
place spot.
And that has been shaken up.
Now I think at this point we have to say that
there is a different paradigm, which is that
the momentum has shifted behind Elizabeth
Warren.
I can't think of another candidate who is
even remotely in this thing who has the momentum
of Elizabeth Warren right now.
So let's take a look first at what the polls
look like in general.
You're, you'll notice if you're watching along
with me, the Green Line at the top going above
40% several months ago is Joe Biden and Joe
Biden has had his ups and downs.
Now settling at an average of 27 in recent
polls and still in first place for now.
The second line on this graph has been Bernie
Sanders.
And as you can see, Bernie Sanders, uh, steadily
in second place for many, many months.
Although you have seen a sort of convergence
of the brown line, which is Elizabeth Warren,
who is polling right around 6% months ago,
slowly but steadily climbing, climbing, climbing,
and now actually jumping into second place.
Statistically in an average of recent polls
ahead of Bernie Sanders, 18.3 to 16.3 this
is of course an average of recent polls.
Now some important caveats, 18.3 versus 16.3
is not some massive Gulf.
We could get one more post third debate poll
and this could completely reverse itself and
Bernie Sanders could be exactly tied with
Warren or a head.
These are general numbers that give us a sense
of the momentum.
Now even more important arguably in terms
of the number of polls, if you look right
now at the last 10 poles or the last 12 poles
or the last 14 poles, what you will see is
that in half of them Bernie Sanders is in
second place and half of them Elizabeth Warren
is in second place.
A recency is weighted slightly more in these
averages of recent pollings.
And there is one particular recent poll in
which Elizabeth Warren is solidly in second
place.
That's where this average comes from.
So now that we've seen this trend line of
Elizabeth Warren climbing with Bernie Sanders,
sort of holding steady, and again, please
don't shoot the Messenger.
I hope that we're beyond the point of making
personal attacks on me merely for reporting
to you what it is that the polls say.
As many of you know, I am a Bernie Warren
Guy.
I think that there are upsides to both of
them.
I think that together they are a very strong
progressive sort of duo in the Democratic
primary.
This is, we're just talking about the polls.
Don't kill the Messenger.
Okay, and by the way, if you're going to write
to me and say the polls are only polling old
people on landlines, we debunked that multiple
times.
That's not true.
Let's really keep the conversation productive
rather than resorting to this stuff.
So we have to post debate data points.
Right now, the debate was last Thursday.
We have two polls that were conducted after
that debate.
The first is the politico morning consult
poll.
This is the poll in which Bernie Sanders is
still in second place.
Joe Biden 32 Bernie Sanders, 20 Elizabeth
Warren, 18 Bernie and Warren statistically
tied, but Bernie Sanders I had 20 to 18.
You'll also notice that we still have seen
no changes anywhere else to suggest that anybody
other than Biden, Sanders and Warren even
remotely have a shot at this thing.
Kamala Harris, despite some people on my Twitter
telling me she obviously won the debate, nothing
happening.
She's still at 6%.
Pete booted judge at five Beto maybe gaining
a little bit up to 4% a booker and Yang both
at three in club a char a too.
So, um, that is one of the two post debate
polls.
This one has a statistical tie between Bernie
and Warren with Bernie ahead by two.
The second post debate poll that we have is
an NBC News Wall Street Journal poll and this
is the one that has Elizabeth Warren very
solidly in second place, 25 to Bernie Sanders,
14 with Biden still in first place with 31
now I do find it difficult to believe that
Bernie Sanders is polling only 14% nationally
given everything else that we've seen recently.
But, and again, I'm just the Messenger.
I'm just the analyst.
I like Bernie I, it sucks that I have to do
these disclaimers, but they do help to mitigate
a little bit of the crazy messages I get.
There are actually now several recent polls
which have Bernie near 14 the hill last week
had him at 15 the economist had him at 16
Reuters had them at 16 and after the debate,
the third debate last week, I actually got
a ton of emails from people saying, David,
I like Bernie, but I think that he's done,
and some attributing it to the stagnant poll
numbers relative to Elizabeth Warren's momentum.
A lot of people emailing me saying, you know,
Bernie certainly didn't help himself with
his voice being horse for the first half of
the debate combined with Elizabeth Warren
getting to do rebuttals before Bernie almost
every time since their views were very similar
in terms of the content of their rebuttals.
Bernie came off as if he was just saying,
me too to Warren merely because they went
to her first for rebuttals, but more people
than we've had in the last six months.
Contacting me saying Bernie is done and and
I hope that that's not the case.
I don't believe Bernie has done from any objective
point of view at this point in time, but anybody
who's looking at the polling has to realize
that the momentum is with Elizabeth Warren
and if you look at a recent polls, if you
look at the same polls over the last four
months, you will notice that Joe Biden has
on average lost a little bit.
Bernie Sanders is roughly even to have lost
a little bit and Elizabeth Warren has just
been steadily gaining one-to-one and a half
points a month.
So a momentum undoubtedly with Elizabeth Warren.
Now the conversation I want to have with you
soon is about Bernie versus Warren.
Putting aside our personal feelings about
things like who do we like better personality
wise, putting aside even everything but thinking
objective Lee about the pragmatics of their
platform.
There is the idea which I'm reading about
more and more that while Elizabeth Warren
is certainly more moderate than Bernie Sanders,
even though particularly domestically, their
policies are similar.
I'm starting to see more and more starting
to see more and more a opinions that Elizabeth
Warren may be more effective as president
in that her ideas are more likely to be able
to be made effective via law policy or executive
order, then those of Bernie Sanders.
Now that's a very general statement.
I think if we really want to deal with that
seriously, we have to look at, okay, let's
look at healthcare, Bernie versus Warren.
Why specifically if we are making the case
that Warren's plan is more likely to be made
a reality than Bernie's, why is it that we're
saying that when it comes to inequality, what
specifically about Elizabeth Warren's plan
versus Bernie's is more likely to become a
reality?
So the question is even if we are more progressive,
let's say, and we find Bernie to be more progressive
than Warren and I believe in a marginal sense
he is, is there a way in which effective progress
may be higher with Elizabeth Warren because
she may be more likely to get, you know, a
few Republicans on board or whatever the case
may be.
I am merely asking the question, I am not
telling you that that's the case.
It's a pretty classic pragmatism versus idealism
conversation.
But sometimes when people say idealism, there's
like a negative connotation attached to it
or some kind of dismissive element.
I love Bernie's ideas.
So when I say idealism, what I mean is the
ideas are great ideas and completely not controversial
in many parts of the world that seemed to
have things figured out in northern Europe
and elsewhere.
It's merely a practical question and we're
going to be dealing with this soon.
But before I deal with it, I want to hear
from you about it.
Um, let me know your thoughts on that in terms
of the practicality and potential for, for
really affecting change with President Bernie
versus President Warren.